six seven eight nine ten Pressey good
test one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten good all right thank you
what's that
one two three four five yes mister
sorry guys
you know
yeah
okay
I'm sure that sounds fine we're trying
to start going you know visualize
neither gray cable employment
a little tangled there
it works
tomorrow
zemerik
so
[Music]
boom I got you now
yeah exactly
hey Joe as the wallet to be the backup
offense
they're asking you to pan left
I am wolf we just scrambled together for
this roseguard news conference may just
be a statement from the president
coming up at 6:30 and just a few moments
from now he tweeted that this is going
to be happening at 6:30 and we expect
these remarks to be brief we'll see if
he takes questions obviously we've seen
some pretty stunning sights over here at
the White House over the last hour or so
we saw about eight military vehicles
large military vehicles Rumble through
the White House complex carrying us
troops over at Pennsylvania Avenue to
help bolster some of the protective
forces that are in place for tonight's
potential unrest one of the things that
we know that the president may talk
about because press secretary talked
about this earlier today Caylee mcenany
told reporters that president is
considering where it's being considered
inside White House the use of the 1807
insurrection Act which allows the
president as a US government to deploy
US military troops to help
while a disturbance now obviously this
is a very old there gonna be a lot of
legal experts who are going to argue
over whether or not this is appropriate
but the site of US military forces
rolling through the White House complex
in a situation like this book is just
highly irregular and is obviously going
to cause a lot of concern for people
around the country and nici guests
around the world as the United States is
looked upon as a beacon of democracy it
isn't every day it's very rare to see
military vehicles rolling through the
White House complex and we also saw the
Attorney General's go far outside the
White House inspecting the situation
going on in Lafayette Park there's been
discussions inside the administration
about multiple agencies sending their
protective units to Lafayette Park to
make sure this place does not get out of
control as we saw last night fires were
sent to places around the White House
inside Saint John's Episcopal Church
streets asking these governors why they
aren't using their our troops and so on
and so he has been kind of laying down
this marker that he's ready to get top
about the use
first Airborne Division of the US Army
potentially using the Kirby
unrest here in Washington around the
country so just a rant of rhetoric that
we just have never really seen before in
my lifetime haven't seen in generations
in this country and I suppose the
question is whether or not any of this
works for the president I will tell you
wolf there has been debate or my
colleagues and I in the CNN White House
team have been reporting on this all day
long has been debate inside the
president's team of advisers as to
whether or not he should talk about any
of this
because there's the potential he could
make matters worse we saw last week when
he tweeted about looters being shot that
obviously helped inflame the situation
there's just no way around that and the
potential is there once again wolf for
the President to walk out in the Rose
Garden of the White House after US
military vehicles just rolled through
this complex and inflamed things further
that's what going to be watching for
that's right governor Pritzker from
Illinois me was telling the president on
this conference called that your
rhetoric is not helping the situation
it's hurting the situation and that the
president should be displaying a style
of leadership that brings in the country
I and the president responded to that by
saying I don't like your rhetoric either
and you didn't do very well dealing with
the coronavirus and so he's in a very
feisty
[Music]
you can see them walk
to the
I don't want that they're going to need
anything
thank you
yeah
yeah
there
my curious
they're giving me directions
we can hear the explosions
we sure can yes but we are standing in
the Roseburg right now waiting for the
Presidents come out and address the
nation and as he is about to address the
nation we can hear the explosions
Lafayette Park there very clearly
audible and so we are now seeing the
potential for the president to be
addressing the nation as these
explosions are going up at the same time
I mean that is just an absolutely
unbelievable prospect but that's what
we're facing here at this very moment we
can hear those flashbacks coming in
after we've been hearing over the last
couple of days of breaking out right now
now we do expect the President to
deliver a lawn order
focused address the teleprompters of our
set up and so we'll be seeing as that's
described from time to time teleprompter
Trump that potentially means he will be
taking any questions but as you know
expect the unexpected with the president
he may deliver these remarks and then
decide to take questions
said he's going to be explaining why we
saw those military vehicles transferring
those troops over to the park to try to
help follow this disturbance
now obviously question is going to be
asked and try to ask the question as he
walks out of here he doesn't take any
questions you know where where is the
message of where is the message of
trying to calm things down around this
country because obviously you can send
in the cavalry you can send all of these
military forces that doesn't necessarily
make the protestors go away unless you
want to really crack some skulls out
there and that is those are images that
this White House has to realize comes
with a massive political press beginning
that's right well then we just heard
three more explosions and I can tell you
when that tear gas is fired our on the
street near the White House you can
smell it down the block it is not
something that you just have to be in
that same vicinity in order to
experience that and I think it does beg
the question why is the president
delivering this address of the nation
and the Rose Garden where clearly we're
going to hear these explosions and there
is the potential that you could happen
tear gas
[Music]
if you let me know you see message
[Music]
Jim to minute-to-minute morning
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States Donald J Trump
thank you very much
my fellow Americans my first and highest
duty as president is to defend our great
country and the American people I swore
an oath to uphold the laws of our nation
and that is exactly what I will do all
Americans were rightly sickened and
revolted by the brutal death of George
Floyd my administration is fully
committed that for George and his family
justice will be served he will not have
died in vain but we cannot allow the
righteous cries and peaceful protestors
to be drowned out by an angry mob the
biggest victims of the rioting are
peace-loving citizens in our poorest
communities and as their president I
will fight to keep them safe I will
fight to protect you I am your president
of law and order and an ally of all
peaceful protesters but in recent days
our nation has been gripped by
professional anarchists violent mobs
arsonists looters criminals riders and
Tifa and others a number of state and
local governments have failed to take
necessary action to safeguard their
residents innocent people have been
savagely beaten like the young man in
Dallas Texas who was left dying on the
street or the woman in upstate New York
viciously attacked by dangerous thugs
small business owners have seen their
dreams
utterly destroyed New York's finest have
been hit in the face with bricks braved
nurses who have battled the virus are
afraid to leave their homes a police
precinct has been overrun here in the
nation's capital the Lincoln Memorial
and the World War Two memorial
have been vandalized one of our most
historic churches was set ablaze a
federal officer in California an
african-american enforcement hero was
shot and killed these are not acts of
peaceful protests these are acts of
domestic terror the destruction of
innocent life and the spilling of
innocent blood is an offense to humanity
and a crime against God
America needs creation not destruction
cooperation not contempt security not
anarchy healing not hatred justice not
chaos this is our mission and we will
succeed 100% we will succeed our country
always wins that is why I am taking
immediate presidential action to stop
the violence and restore security and
safety in America I am mobilizing all
available federal resources civilian and
military to stop the rioting and looting
to end the destruction and arson and to
protect the rights of law-abiding
Americans including your second
Amendment rights therefore the following
measures are going into effect
immediately
first we are ending the riots and
lawlessness that has spread throughout
our country we will end it now
today I have strongly recommended to
every governor to deploy the National
Guard in sufficient numbers that we
dominate the streets mayors and
governors must establish an overwhelming
law enforcement presence until the
violence has been quelled if a city or
state refuses to take the actions that
are necessary to defend the life and
property of their residents
then I will deploy the United States
military and quickly solve the problem
for
them I am also taking swift and decisive
action to protect our great capital
Washington DC what happened in this city
last night was a total disgrace as we
speak I am dispatching thousands and
thousands of heavily armed soldiers
military personnel and law enforcement
officers to stop the rioting looting
vandalism assaults and the wanton
destruction of property we are putting
everybody on warning our seven o'clock
curfew will be strictly enforced those
who threaten innocent life and property
will be arrested detained and prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law I want
the organizers of this terror to be on
notice that you will face severe
criminal penalties and lengthy sentences
in jail this includes an tyfa and others
who are leading instigators of this
violence one law and order and that is
what it is one law we have one beautiful
law and once that is restored and fully
restored we will help you we will help
your business and we will help your
family America is founded upon the rule
of law it is the foundation of our
prosperity our freedom and our very way
of life but where there is no law if
there is no opportunity where there is
no justice there is no Liberty where
there is no safety there is no future we
must never give in to anger or hatred
if malice or violence reigns then none
of us is free I take these actions today
with firm resolve and with a true and
passionate love for our country by far
our greatest days lie ahead thank you
very much
and now I'm going to pay my respects to
a very very special place thank you very
much